the Washington National Cathedral has
replaced its stained glass with BLM type
propaganda
the cathedral has unveiled a set of four
new stained glass windows just this past
Saturday dedicated to the theme of
racial Justice
and those installations were to replace
the previous windows which
depicted Stonewall Jackson which
depicted Robert E Lee which depicted
some of the great figures of the South
and of the reconciliation that took
place after the Civil War my first
thought is
episcopalians are going to Episcopalian
you know this is what they do
it's sad to say I have listened some of
my very best friends in Episcopalian
okay but
there's that good old line variously
attributed to Dean Inge or Fulton Sheen
which is that if you wed the spirit of
the age you'll find yourself a widow in
the next and the episcopalians gotta
love them but they have particularly
fallen into this trap so now an
Episcopalian service at Episcopalian
public life is just a series of
political fads it's really not all that
different from just watching a liberal
newscast and so it's no surprise that
they would get rid of these stained
glass windows and replace them with the
new fashions of whatever the vision of
racial Justice is today but don't forget
it's not like they were replacing
stained glass windows of the evangelists
stained glass windows of the Saints
they were replacing stabilized Windows
of Stonewall Jackson and Robert E Lee
why why were those even the stained
glass windows well because
after the Civil War
those windows were put up as a sign of
coming back together this war that
almost ripped the country completely in
in half it was it was a gracious gesture
for the conquered people the conquered
people being in the South and this is
what's so strange about this new moment
and this little symbol in the churches
the the old windows honored the
conquered South the new windows honor
the conquerors I'm not I don't mean
racial conquerors I mean ideological
conquerors
the old windows look the north won the
War the Union won the war and yet they
paid a little bit of homage to the South
the new windows pay homage to
progressivism the progressive view of
History the past was really bad the
future is going to be really good the
president is always a crisis
white people bad black people good old
people bad young people good
the the new windows honor the the
ideological conquerors because
progressivism has has conquered the
country that is the uh ideology that
animates the whole country now
and so you would think if they wanted to
keep this in line with the old windows
they would maybe pay some homage to the
conservatives or to the normal people or
to maybe Christians wouldn't that be
nice in our National Cathedral if they
had the windows honoring Saints and
honoring uh evangelists and honoring
figures from the Bible but no that's not
how it works
the the days of malice toward none and
charity for all the days of extending an
olive branch to the Concord
that's over that the the progressive see
no role for that they see no role for
Grace because the progressives have sold
out the religion that animated our
entire civilization Christianity and
they've replaced it with political
stained glass windows one thing that I
really don't like when I'm on the road I
have a good time when I'm on the road I
like meeting the students I like giving
the speeches I like the Q a one thing I
don't like them is that I don't get to
eat delicious good ranchers right now go
to goodranchors.com use code Knowles
this is the thing that I I hate about
being on the road
the one thing is I don't get to eat my
delicious good ranchers because sweet
little Elise has got it at home I love
good ranchers it is the absolute best
meat out there
it comes straight to your door you can
pick what you want to be for the pork or
the chicken or the fish now it's just so
freaking good it's 100 American you also
can get uh 500 in savings if you order
right now they'll also lock in your
price for two years which is completely
insane uh no other company guarantees
you 100 American Meat and a locked in
price the quality is absolutely through
the roof save right now eat the way that
I eat I good ranchers has turned sweet
little Elisa into a ribeye eater it has
it has completely changed my view on
ground beef because it's the greatest
burgers out there this deal is not going
to last forever go to goodranchors.com
use code Knolls Canada WLS for 25 bucks
off and free ground beef for two years
lock in your price on America's best
meat for two whole years
goodranchers.com use Cardinals for over
500 bucks in savings
subscribe to good ranchers American Meat
delivered speaking of dubious narratives
there's a new crisis guys Democrats have
an urgent campaign
they want to reinstate net neutrality
do you remember net neutrality it's been
about six years now I still don't really
know what net neutrality is
all I was told in 2017
When Donald Trump was about to get rid
of net neutrality
was that this was going to destroy the
internet we weren't going to be able to
the internet as we knew it was going to
be over not only that people were going
to die
this is what they told us if
some executive agency changed some
slight rule about how the isps were
regulated and then what happened they
got rid of net neutrality and
everything was fine actually the only
thing that changed was that internet
speeds increased a little bit but
everything else
it was fine your bill didn't really
change you're not nothing nothing
changed well anyway the Democrats want
to reinstate it 27 Senate Democrats have
written a letter to the chairman of the
FCC Jessica Rosen warsell
urging her to reinstate the title II
regulations on isps known as net
neutrality uh they they want to defend
the free and open internet which Remain
the only the only thing that
risks making the internet no longer free
and open is when the Democrats come in
and censor everything on the internet
otherwise it's pretty free and open but
the Democrats just want to be totally
sure and so they want to reinstate new
neutrality what we can learn from this
is nothing about the internet it's
nothing really about regulation or isps
what we can learn from this
is that the Democrats the libs
never give up they never give up not
even on that Teensy tiniest least
significant things
they are always plowing ahead with their
agenda
conservatives I'm sorry to say we're not
always like that sometimes we are
we've held the line on life on the issue
of abortion even after Roe v Wade in
1973 the conservatives held firm and we
kept pushing pushing pushing then
eventually
we got to overrule
the terrible decision in Roe v Wade that
was great but in a lot of issues we just
Let It Go all marriage yeah that's over
we lost that one oh the structure of the
government the way our constitutional
works oh yeah okay yeah well we lost
that one it's no big deal oh well you
know porn on the ubiquitous porn on the
Internet yeah there's nothing really we
can do sorry we lost that one ah well
blah blah blah the Democrats never think
that way and we should emulate them
we should notice that they just if they
take a loss even if it's the end of the
world catastrophic loss of net
neutrality falling away they just plow
ahead and six years later they remember
this stupid rule from the FCC we need to
do that too boy what a great clip that
was now make sure that you ring the bell
subscribe to Michael Knowles Channel see
you next time